never marry someone who's not nice she's
very nice
I don't know I hit the jackpot Felicity
Huffman and William H Macy may not be
feeling so lucky and in love right now
since felicity was named among the 50
people involved in the College Admission
scandal a source tells ET the couple has
been arguing a lot and quote this
situation has been very trying on
felicity and Williams marriage
the former Desperate Housewives star
along with fuller house star Lauri
Lachlan were charged in the cheating
scam Felicity was arrested after
allegedly paying fifteen thousand
dollars so their college-age daughter
Sophia Grace could get help on the SAT
exam
the actress faces charges of conspiracy
to commit mail fraud she's currently out
on a 250 thousand dollar bond
her husband William was not charged in
the case make no mistake this is not a
case where parents were acting in the
best interests of their children this is
a case where they flaunted their wealth
sparing no expense to cheat the system
so they could set their children up for
success with the best education money
could buy
literally some spent anywhere from two
hundred thousand to six and a half
million dollars for guaranteed admission
their actions were without a doubt
insidious selfish and shameful a source
close to the couple tells ET many of
their friends were stunned by the news
quote they've always seemed like honest
good people people who would never lie
and cheat to get what they wanted now we
all keep asking ourselves why would they
do this it makes no sense Felicity and
William have been married for over
twenty years and share two daughters
eighteen-year-old Sophia and 17-year old
Georgia our source adds Felicity and
William have an incredibly strong
marriage but this situation has put a
tremendous amount of pressure on them
one can help your children in this
business and the nepotism works and I
have no problems with it and if I can
give them a leg up I absolutely would
it's a great way to make a living it
really is that was William back in 2004
telling et about the benefits his kids
have because his status in showbiz the
56 year old has also been open about her
challenges in motherhood I think
particularly mothering and if you do it
well you work yourself right out of a
job because God willing your kids don't
need you if you do it badly and you've
damaged your kids enough they're gonna
you their whole life so it's kind of a
toss-up in the wake of the scandal
felicity has since deleted her social
media accounts she is due back in court
in Boston on March 29th